hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i
am a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be answering your property
investment
questions the thing is i've been
investing in property now for 12 years
i've done
over 300 property deals i did my first
property bill 12 years ago it was a hmo
and i've experienced so many challenges
and problems
in property so that's why i like to take
a moment every single week on sunday at
7 pm
to answer all your challenging questions
your problems
and help you so that you can also become
a successful property investor or
entrepreneur
so if you like my property channel
please do me a massive favor
and smash the like button that really
helps me out
also subscribe to the channel if you're
not already subscribed turn the
notification
bell on and i'm only able to do this if
you actually ask me questions so
in the comment box below ask me any
question you like about property
investment
and i'll do my best to answer next week
however right now i've got a whole bunch
of questions to go through from last
week
and this might help you out a lot so if
you enjoy the video smash the like
button let's see what we've got
sm says hi samuel thank you for all the
q a sundays you're so welcome
my question is when buying a hmo
property in an article 4
area what evidence do i need to make
sure
i can continue renting it out as a hmo
the estate agent has said the property
is an
authorized hmo but so far has not shown
me any documents confirming this
thanks okay sm the answer is you're
going to need to see the
tenancy agreements from the tenants
to the landlord in the hmo property and
when you buy the house if it's already
an article 4 area
but it's being used as a hmo you want to
see that it was used as a hmo
prior to article 4 coming in
so you can find out when article 4 came
into that area
by googling it and it should be on the
council website and you're going to want
to see
an ast assured short hold tenancy
from the tenants renting rooms prior
before the date of article 4 coming in
if they can prove that and show those
ast contracts
then there will be planning permission
granted on the property
meaning it is safe to buy i hope that
helps thanks for your great question
what else do we have thomas kelly samuel
i've just bought a house for 45 000
pounds in northern ireland
going to put maybe five thousand pounds
into a refurb once that's done
can i get a new mortgage on the property
to pull equity out
thomas yes you probably can um there's a
couple
factors that you're gonna need to bear
in mind number one is if you spend five
thousand pounds on the property how much
have you actually pushed the value up by
if if it's worth 45 grand and you spend
five grand on it
but you've only pushed the value up by
five grand it might not be worth
getting a new a new mortgage because
you're only going to get 75
of the equity and it's only 5 000 pounds
worth of equity which is about three
grand
and the early penalty charges are
probably going to be more than that
and are there early penalty charges and
how much
is the property gonna be pushed up i
mean if if you bought it for 45
and you're spending five grand on it
strategically and it's going to push it
up to 65 000 pounds
then sure refinance it normally you have
to own a property six months before
refinancing
there are some lenders that will let you
do it sooner but it's very limited
and because you've got limited lenders
you're going to end up probably paying
higher interest rates
so i hope that helps and good luck on
your continued property journey
all right what else ht under what
circumstances will the bank give you a
mortgage as an 18 year old
for a buy chilled property um ht
they will probably not do it but my
understanding
is you have to be 21 now you might be
thinking but hang on a minute samuel
you're 29
you said you'd be investing in property
for 12 years so how's that work
out and the answer is rather than me
begging the banks to give me a buy to
let mortgage that wasn't going to happen
when i was a teenager they were saying
21 21 21 21
so instead i started begging my family
members to be a mortgage host or
guarantor
on my early property investment so
there's always a way around it there's
always a solution
it's sometimes about asking the right
questions rather than necessarily having
all the right answers
good luck 18 year old boy you're going
to kick some ass
daniel oliver with a hmo property do you
need to have wash basins in every
bedroom as part of
licensing the answer is no you do not
need a a
wash basin in every bedroom as part of
license ink um
nope you know manchester youtube hi
samuel another question please
if i have 10 000 pounds is there any way
that's enough to start with a bridging
finance
if you've got 10 grand and you're trying
to use that
to buy a property and the rest get on
bridging
i'm going to be really honest you're
going to struggle and the reason is is
because most bridging companies
they're going to want to put in about 65
which means you're going to need to put
in about 45 percent
45 of as a deposit 10 grand isn't going
to cut it even if the house is like 40
grand
it's not going to be enough so i don't
think it is going to be enough
to to go and buy a house with bridging
finance that's the bad news
the good news is that bridging companies
don't care
where your deposit comes from within
reason so
if you're if you've only got 10 grand
but you found a really good deal
and you want to get bridging on it
usually 10 grand but maybe borrow
another 10 grand from a friend a joint
investor
a joint investor partner an angel
investor
a bank loan they don't care the bridging
company cares about more about the
property than where you're putting the
deposit from
and then you can then refinance it once
you've done the work so
um i hope that helps and as i as i've
said many many times i'm not a mortgage
advisor
so i would also get mortgage advice on
this um
but that will be the strategy that i'd
be looking to do you've got to raise
some finance
raise some finance 10k won't get you
very far in property if you haven't got
the ability
to raise finance so hope that helps all
right
sam hb hi samuel great videos i'm 19 and
i'm starting my journey on learning
about investing in property i hear you
mention that you can pull out all your
money
out of deals when you refinance a house
it is possible but not always it depends
on the house
however this still leaves you in debt so
there
is there a point banks won't let you
take out any more mortgages
because you already have a lot of debt
and surely
it's not good to get too much debt even
if it means you have many properties
thanks um okay so no
generally speaking it doesn't matter how
much debt you've got look donald trump
is probably the highest debt worth
person on the planet um people that have
a high net worth
usually also have a high debt worth debt
is just the way that businesses operate
so the question that banks are going to
want to know is
what security do they have and how are
you going to be paying the
interest on that debt debt is just a
tool
now if you're borrowing bad debt yeah
for sure there's going to be a point
where when lenders are going to be like
oh hold on a minute
you're already up to your eyeballs in
debt i don't know how you're going to
pay this back
but if you're borrowing money and you're
strategically investing it
then that's just called business so i
mean sure if you're buying residential
houses
you can only usually own two residential
mortgages because
you're living in there so they're
thinking well hold on a minute you can't
keep buying all these houses because
because they're residential houses for
you to live in how are you going to
pay all these mortgages but if you're
buying a property as an investment
and you're renting it out lenders will
just see that as safe and secure
so i mean there are some lenders small
time lenders that might say
oh we only let you have five or ten
houses
but generally speaking as long as you're
a smart investor you're not going to
struggle to get debt in fact the more
debt you have as long as you can
show and demonstrate that you're using
it smart the better so
you've got to get your head around the
difference between good debt and bad
debt i always say bad debt is
really bad but good debt is really good
so it will serve you
and it will help leverage your business
and bring more cash flow and more net
worth and more value into your business
and into your life hope that helps
all right marnie ali can i use a bounce
back loan as a deposit on a house and do
you think this is a good idea
yeah listen if you can i think it's a
great idea if you can
as long as it doesn't when you get any
kind of loan
so a bounce back loan is a loan and a
mortgage
is a loan so there's always going to be
restrictions to that loan
balance back loans there's not that many
restrictions to bounce back loans
they're not too uh there's not too many
rules around bounce back loans mortgages
that there are a little bit more
restrictive because when you get a
mortgage they're going to ask you things
like
where's the deposit coming from they're
going to ask you um what
purpose the property is going to be used
for so if you're getting a mortgage
you might not be able to use a bounce
back loan as a deposit um
if you're doing if you're getting a
bridging finance and you're buying a brr
deal
then then you most likely would be able
to so
yeah i think i think dare if you're if
you're taking a bounce back loan or any
kind of loan and you're using it as good
debt and it's and it's serving you well
i think it's a good idea i think it's
smart
so as long as you're not breaking any
rules or lying
when you when you take on that debt
about what you're going to do with it um
i hope that helps tyrone saxton
hey good to have you here again um i
have a question i need help with samuel
i have a four-bedroomed hmo one tenant
has two
children between the age of eight and
fourteen they stay over around twice a
week
as it has come to my recent attention
the tenant with when he has his two
children stay over
makes the others in the hmo feel
overcrowded in the communal spaces such
as the living room
what is the best way to handle this in
future i will not get tenants who have
children ever again
okay tyrone um there's two things going
on here
there's house rules and then there's
tenancy rules so
when you actually have a someone that's
interested in moving into your property
uh you will have a tenancy agreement
like an ast contract for instance
and in the ast contract you can
put in there the what what the tenancy
is so you can say things like
this room you can only have one person
sleeping in this room and you can have
you can have
basic tenancy rules also on top of that
if there's anything that's a little bit
uh see an ast contract um like generally
speaking
people can stay over twice a week
because that's not classed as living
there i think it's if it's three times
or more when
when it's class is living there but but
you can just have house rules
so in the hr you can just say look these
are the rules um
you know you allow you're allowed guests
um to come over but only one guest at a
time and for only
for only one night at a time you know
not lots of consent
so you can just have some house rules
and then when you're showing tenants
around prospective tenants just tell
them what the house rules are and if
they've got lots of kids they want to be
bringing over three times a week
then they're going to see the house
rules they're going to see the asd
contracts and then you know it's not
really the idea
and then they won't move in and if they
do move in you can then say hang on
it says this on the house rules which
you which you agreed to and you were
told when you move in
with hmos it's really important just in
general to have house rules
because without rules people just make
up their own thing
and then arguments come so yeah it
sounds like you're in a bit of a tricky
situation i would personally be trying
to get rid of
that tenant i'd be but but not in a
nasty way you don't even have to evict
them i'd be just saying look you know
what
i don't really think you're cut out for
a hmo um
so how about this i'll give you a
deposit back um i'll give you and just
make it
sweet for them uh but i'd be wanting to
get rid of them because otherwise the
other tenants in your hmm might move out
and then suddenly you've got this one
tenant and then they're going to start
taking over the whole house
but just paying one room's rent
so i'd be willing to get rid of them as
fast as possible and replace them with
with someone who's a bit more suitable
good luck keep us posted
burning desire hi samuel prices seem to
be inflated right now do you think this
is temporary
should we wait and wait it out and start
buying in a year's time when the economy
is downhill
also i feel areas which are mostly
rented
these house prices could even rise as
investors will always keep up the demand
it's areas where residents buy their own
house which will be affected when job
losses happen i think that's a question
at the end um
look house prices right now we're in a
mini boom so house prices are really
going crazy and people are queuing up
and they're out bidding each other and
zumping each other do i think that's uh
temporary yes i do
i think that there's going to be a dip
real soon uh in the next few months
we'll see that
and i think the dips gonna happen when
when furlough stops
when when our business owners stop
paying their staff and start firing more
people because furlough stops
um when uh there's a lot of things at
the moment and i said this was gonna
happen i predicted this
about four or five months ago i said
that the government are gonna
manufacture
a a bit of a boom and they're gonna try
and desperately try and push the economy
up and that's what's happening right now
um that's gonna there's gonna be a dip
but then ultimately i think house prices
are gonna continue rising strong again
so it just depends on what your strategy
is should you buy right now
um you could buy right now if the return
on investment is good but just make sure
you don't get wrapped up in any bidding
wars and you don't overpay for a house
hope that helps adam barnes what is a
good right for buy to let limited
company
mortgages at this present time if it's
three point something percent that's
pretty decent
uh ollie wilson hi samuel i really want
to start investing in property but i'm
scared that i will invest
and then need the money that is tied up
in property for whatever reason
how easy is it to sell the property if
you have a tenant in there thanks
ollie wilson um look property i guess
it's a blessing and a curse at the same
time
is not very liquid and what i mean by
not very liquid
is like money in the bank is a terrible
investment and your cash is going to be
shrinking
and i wouldn't suggest having lots and
lots of money in the bank
but it's very liquid in other words if
you need it
you can get it real quick um gold
is very liquid because you can take gold
and you can go to the
go to a pawn shop and you can just give
it to them and get money
you know fast property is not very
liquid property
if you've got property and you want to
sell it it takes a long time to get the
money and if you're in a rush
to get the money you're going to end up
probably dropping the price and selling
it below market value which is a bit of
a pain to have to do that
now the reason that's a not a good thing
it's a curse is because
it's annoying if you suddenly need money
but the reason it's a blessing is
because it
locks your money away money in the bank
gets bored
and board money disappears if you lock
it into property
then you can't touch it so you're not
going to be able to spend it
so having illiquid assets has got its
perks
um if you're potentially going to need
the money in in three months time
i wouldn't suggest putting all that
money into a property um
so yeah how easy to sell a property
it's not that easy it's to take time it
could take three months
at best it could take six months it
could take a year um
so that is one of the one of the i guess
the downsides to property but also one
of the upsides often what happens is
people put all their money
in property and then suddenly there's a
recession or they're a bit skinned and
they're like oh no and they need the
money
but they can't get it but actually
that's a good thing because if the money
was in the bank they just spend it and
they have nothing so it's kind of good
to be locked away
another good thing about having property
is you're going to be able to just get
the cash flow so you
lock the money up but then you use the
rent and you just
spend the rent so ollie if i was you i
wouldn't be thinking about putting the
money in property and then how soon can
i quickly
sell the house and get it back property
is a long-term game should be putting
the money in the property and then the
rent that's coming in
using that as your liquid cash so anyway
i hope that helps
dabo gaming hi samuel i've recently
inherited 150 000 pounds but currently
don't have a job would it still be
possible for me to get a buy to let
mortgage thank you for your time
uh yeah quite possibly so again most buy
to let lenders
they don't mind about your income they
care more about the investment because
they know that you're going to have to
pay them back because if the property's
a good buy to let property
they're more concerned about is this
property going to rent out nicely
if you haven't got a job i'd speak to a
mortgage broker and see what you can do
maybe
i've known people have become
self-employed and their salary is like
five grand a year and they can go and
get buy to let mortgages so
speak to a broker see what they say adam
aldridge dear samuel i'm just starting
out with property investment
good for you i have 25 000 pounds for a
down payment and i'm thinking of
purchasing a house or a flat costing
about 80 grand to rent out
my question is about mortgages should i
go for a longer duration plan of say
20 years getting more take home from the
rent money
yes you should do that but but paying
more interest
you're not paying more interest um i
guess
unless you're going to pay off real
quick and then you're not going to pay
much interest but then that would be not
good
um or should i get a short-term mortgage
you'll say five to ten years paying less
interest overall but with less rent
money left over or even payments to make
up look adam you don't want to pay the
mortgage off in my opinion you want to
get a mortgage for as long as possible
fix the interest rates for as long as
possible as low as possible then get
cash flow
get as much cash flow cash flow is kink
as much cash flow as possible then save
up that cash flow and then buy another
house and then get now you've got two
lots of cash flow
and the goal is to get as much monthly
cash flow as you can
from your property business giving you
passive income so you are now
financially free that's the goal
hope that helps bick hi there
though the kitchen was damaged during my
occupancy
my landlord has refused to fix it hence
i only pay 700 pounds instead of 900
pounds
and two weeks late on the basis the
property is not worth a rental of 900.
where do i stand up getting evicted as
per my situation not paying landlord in
full and on time as per ast contract
thanks in advance so beck
um that's not really good in my opinion
uh because
okay you say that it's not worth 900
pounds so you're only paying 700 pounds
but when you signed the contract at your
ast contract
you agreed that you would pay 900 pounds
so if you don't think it's worth 9 in
japan then you shouldn't have agreed to
pay it
now you might argue that no because now
the kitchen's damaged and the landlord's
refusing to fix it therefore this
property is not worth 900 pounds
but what i would say is that's a
separate issue so
in your ast contract your agreement was
to pay 900 pounds to the landlord
i imagine the landlord's agreement was
to make sure the property is in good
repair so
if the property's not in good repair and
he's not doing his job
you need to you've got a contract you
need to say hey
you signed this agree you know you you
can't just go oh well if you're not
going to stick to your agreement then i
won't stick to my agreement and
like it's a separate issue so you know i
i i'll be like
in business i just don't think you can
just say oh you're not sticking to your
agreement
therefore i won't stick to mine you need
to say you want to get your agreement
and we have a contract so and then you
need to enforce that they do
um however that's that you know that's
my opinion
uh let me know what you think in the
comments as well and bick i'm interested
in your
feedback on this uh where do i stand and
getting evicted
so right now yes the landlord might hand
your notice in he might
he might have noticed but he cannot take
you to court and evict you right now
however if you're not paying your full
rent if you're just paying 700 instead
of 900 and you're paying late
even though he can't evict you right now
because of the pandemic
in time he will be able to evict you
because the pandemic will be hopefully
over
and then you're going to have to pay
back all the
rent that you didn't pay and even though
that might be a long time before he
actually takes you to court
um you're now going to have a big bill
and if you say well i'm not paying it
you know screw you then it's going to
make you uh
end up probably with a county court
judgment you're going to be blacklisted
and then when you come to rent a
property again they're going to see your
ref you won't have a reference you're
not gonna have good credit and you're
gonna really struggle to move into
another property because landlords are
gonna go oh
you were that guy that just only paid
700 pound not 900 pound
and didn't pay and got taken to court so
you might right now be okay and not have
to pay and he probably can't do that
much about it but long term it's going
to get you
back and um i think it's going to so my
advice would be to say
look there's a pandemic going on you
know
the kitchen needs fixing i've been a
really good tenant i'm paying you
for 900 quid look the least you can do
is fix this kitchen because it's really
not cool and speak to the letting agent
speak to the landlord
and um you know that that would be that
would be my
advice so hope that helps sorry if
that's not what you want to hear
but of course you know ultimately it's
your decision all right manchester
youtube
i bought a residential mortgage about
seven months ago due to circumstances i
would like to change it to a buy to let
mortgage or sell the house
how would be the best way to go about it
sell the house is fine you can sell the
house
it's a good time to sell a house in
manchester right now manchester's
booming they're in a mini boom
houses are selling great i've got some
friends that have just sold some houses
in manchester sold really well above
asking price
if you want to switch it from
residential mortgage to buy to let
mortgage
you can either get consent to let so you
can ring up your
lender and say look i've got to change
the circumstances can you please give me
a letter and give me a year or two years
and just give me consent to let
that probably be the best thing to do
and then in time you can actually
decide if you want to officially
refinance or sell the house
uh but i would i would just ask for a
letter for consent to rent the property
out for the next six twelve eighteen
months
angelo um i'm trying i'm
12. i'm 12 years old my goodness um
okay um i'm very interested in property
and property development good
i am still at school i'll be doing my
gcses in a few years
and then a levels afterwards what do you
suggest i do now as a 12 year old so
that i'm ready to buy my first property
when i'm 16 to 18.
also i'd like to study medicine but also
want to have time to continue my
property development and eventually work
from home and support my family from
property development
thanks very much angelo angelo you are
an amazing person
uh you want to buy your first house 16
to 18 years old awesome
my suggestion would be number one would
be you want you want to you want to
study medicine and you want to go into
that industry amazing
it's really important that you do get
good grades if that's what you want to
do you want to become a doctor or
whatever
um so work hard at school
um i would start maybe do a get a
part-time job
and learn about work maybe get a paper
round start washing cars that's what i
did when i was 12
um and start and start just saving money
and it might not seem like a great night
you might think oh my gosh
buying a house you know i need all this
money but it's amazing how much even if
you just put like
five or ten pounds aside a week it's
amazing what can happen over the next
few years and what that can equate to
and then when you are 16 you can start
investing it and compounding it
so my advice would be just to continue
studying continue learning as well
continue watching youtube videos like
this
about property and real estate um and
yeah just to wish you
i just wish you all the best so um i
hope that helps and
i believe that you're gonna absolutely
kill it matt rooney how do i legally
borrow money from family for a budget
deposit okay so if you're gonna be
borrowing money from
family legally for a buy sell deposit
most lenders will want it to be a gift
rather than borrowing money where you're
paying interest
um if it's not a gift and obviously you
don't want to lie
i would suggest borrowing money then
getting a bridging loan
buying a house and then refinancing on a
later date onto a normal buy to let
mortgage and hopefully
push the value up before you do that and
pull your money out dog chow
samuel if i were to buy a lamborghini
200 000 pounds as a present to myself
would i be better to do a monthly
repayment scheme for it or to buy
outright and put it under the business
and put the business name etc on the car
to be able to lose the large amount of
vat on top or is this not a thing
thanks um so dog chow
firstly what i'll say is
lamborghinis i don't know loads about
lamborghinis
but i would definitely suggest if you've
got 200 grand and you don't own any
assets and you're not financially
independent
using that to buy a lamborghini just
because you like lamborghini this is
probably not smart
because i mean listen when i became
financially free i was driving around a
dacia sandero like i think it was a
dacia sunderer
they're like the cheapest cars ever i
did i did buy it brand new i think i
leased it i became a millionaire
i was driving around a range rover
evoque which is like the cheapest range
rover
took me a long time before i actually
bought an expensive car which is a range
rover
um should you do monthly repayment
schemes for it
probably yes because if you put the
whole 200 grand in it
boom that's like a lot of money just
tied up into
probably a liability and tax deductible
wise
like my range rover is not very tax
deductible if you buy a tesla
it's very tax efficient you can claim it
as a business expense lamborghini
probably not
unless hold on we'll get to that in a
second but the reason i would probably
not buy outrights because if you use 200
grand and you just buy the whole car
boom it's like what's he going to do how
much is that going to make you if you
but if you at least if you stagger out
over payments over a couple few years
you can maybe put down 20 30 grand of
deposit and then the rest
put it into real estate and then with
the rents that you're making
use that to put down as the future down
payments the only thing i will say about
lamborghini i don't know in terms of the
vat stuff i'm not too sure probably
speak to a tax accountant um
but with a lamborghini if you buy it and
then you
lease it out so you're actually charging
people to hire it out
that's probably i know people that do
that that's a smart thing to do because
then only is it giving you money
but then maybe i again speak to an
accountant but then it maybe is a
business expense so
speak to an accountant definitely
believe in delayed gratification when it
comes to things like cars
and i also definitely believe in not
tying up loads of money into something
that's going to be
a liability in this you can make it an
asset um but i probably would be
preferred to go down the monthly
repayment routes i hope that helps
good luck in your lamborghini driving
and your real estate business
thanks okay uh lastly joyanta
racksmith why is your course so
expensive
12 000 pounds isn't it better to just
save that
for a mortgage um
because there's two things going on here
isn't it better to save that for a
mortgage
i assume you don't mean that because you
don't want to save you can't buy a
mortgage
i assume what you mean is isn't it
better to save that and then get a
mortgage loan
and then use all that money to buy a
house rather than
investing in a course firstly my i don't
have any courses that are 12 000 pounds
um my most advanced uh package the full
bundle if you do all of my courses
together
lease option boot camp rent to rent
accelerator um
buy refurbished refinance masterclass
joint ventures raising finance lease
option bootcamp if you like
literally all of my courses plus sign up
for 12 months of coaching and mentoring
and
yeah maybe that would come down to about
12 000 pounds
um but why is it so expensive
is that expensive i don't know i mean i
mean
firstly it's it's not expensive if you
compare it to
universities if you compare it to other
property trading companies
um if you think it's expensive then
maybe just do
one course don't do the whole everything
or
or buy my book or keep watching me on
youtube
or take out a 95 pound course like
but anyway to answer the question about
isn't it better to say that up for a
mortgage
uh which i assume you didn't mean that
um again
that's it's down to you i mean
personally if you've got 12 grand saved
that's not going to get you very far in
property because
even if you then get a mortgage you're
going to need
the 12 grand to put down as a deposit
and a deposit's 25
so that means the house is going to need
to be worth 12
24 48 grand to get a 48 grand house
firstly you're probably going to
struggle to get a mortgage on it anyway
and secondly it's going to be a very
small cheap house
and that that's 12 grand just for the
deposit it doesn't cover your stamp duty
it doesn't cover you cover your
solicitor costs it doesn't cover you
having to pay the mortgage broker or a
fee so
you actually by the time you take off
stamp duty and stuff you've probably
only got eight grand for an actual
deposit
so even if you could stretch and then
and save up a little bit more say 15 20
grand you're going to buy a house it's
going to be very very small and you're
going to rent it for what like
350 quid a month then you're going to
have to pay your mortgage payments
you're going to have to pay
management fees you have to pay
maintenance and repairs you're going to
be left with maybe 150 pound a month
and my opinion would be and listen i'm
not saying you should spend 12 grand on
training
but if you've got two people one person
had 12 grand the other had 12 grand
person a used that 12 grand to go on all
the different training to get mentoring
the best mentors and coaching and used
it for that and had no money
and then the other person used their 12
grand to buy a
really crappy little house that gave
them 150 pound a month profit
i think this person as long as they
implemented and took action
knowing about how to raise finance about
joint ventures about rent to rents about
co-deal sourcing about
this person would probably go a lot
further a lot faster
than this person so but listen no one's
ever holding a gun to anyone's hair
telling them what to do with their money
so that's the decision that you need to
make up for yourself
um should you buy a house or should you
do training
my suggestion would be do both there's
an unlimited amount of money there's an
unlimited amount of potential
on this planet get knowledge take
massive action
believe in yourself persist and be
positive that'd be my general advice
folks i hope you enjoyed this video
please do smash the like button if you
haven't already also
please let me know your property
investment questions in the comment box
below
i'll do my best to answer next week and
subscribe
don't forget to turn the notification
bell on okay if you're not subscribed
with the bell on
that means that i might do a video i
might answer your questions i might even
do a crazy video
solely about you and your questions and
you won't even know because you're not
subscribed so subscribe
turn the bell on and i'll see you next
time thanks so much